don't forget to show how to play again
yes
i was just gonna do that so
i think i'll just share like one kind of
tricky approach
that if you're white and you play open
sicilian
you'll probably get this position at
some point
and what i could well i could suggest
it's called the 11 fish variation
and i think it's probably very effective
against
anyone below 1800
which is probably a majority of the chat
so the the move to play here is f4
i don't think i've ever taught this
before
i have seen that a few times but the
idea of f4
is okay obviously controlling space
maybe eventually preparing some kind of
later king side attack
um but more concretely there's ideas of
e5
so if we open leachate's explorer
opening book
the most played move on the chassis is
bishop g7
which is a main move after this and this
or this many times black will just auto
like automatically play bishop g7
f4 makes it so bishop g7 is actually a
mistake
because of e5 and we can see this
reflected
in the wind percentage e5
sometimes isn't good because it kind of
overextends but in this case
uh it's very powerful because it's
supported by f4
and the knight's gonna have to
eventually move so most players take
and after take they play yeah they're
already in big trouble
variation is approved by stockfish 11.
seven fish lol oh 11
what do they call this
yeah this is 11 fish variation i don't
know if i mentioned the name
is it actually approved by stockfish
okay it is yeah e5 e5 is very
problematic for black
like once you've got this position like
white's already much better
um if knight g4
we can yeah we can see at least one cool
trap
bishop b5 now notice
if black blocks with anything on d7 we
win the knight
even bishop b7 we win the knight because
the bishop is pinned
and more tragic for black is of king of
f8
96 has a 100
win rate out of 1596
games i don't know if i've ever seen a
100
win rate out of like so many games
but white wins every single game here
because yeah you're picking up the queen
so it's a cool opening it's incredible
how quickly
black can just die after playing
kind of like an automatic natural dragon
move
that's why if you play the dragon as
black like you kind of have to be
prepared for this
oh very weird name says no this was my
secret
a secret revealed
so do i show how to defend against this
line
we could look at some other moves i mean
stockfish bowl probably refute
everything
actually it says knight fd7 is best try
but this is really ugly for black after
d
after pawnee six if black takes then we
win the
either the queen or the bishop
box hole position is in shambles
we have knight d5 95 is second most
played
but again runs into this
and again if black box on d7 it would
obstruct the defense of the queen
to the knight on d5 we would win the
knight
so king f8 is the best move then we very
calmly castle
and also one more request uh don't
upload this to youtube with the
wait clickbaity title so i can enjoy
this line for a while
wait don't upload this to youtube with a
clickbaity title
oh but now you're giving me ideas i
could put this on youtube
how to crush the dragon
crush in all caps crush the dragon
after seven moves white's basically
crushing here
like look at this win rate ten thousand
people walked into this line
man so many clickbait ideas
and 10 000 people suffered from this
epic
trappy dragon line win quickly
especially how many people fell into
this night g4 line
and almost 1 600 people
maybe i'll hold off for like a few days
because i have a lot of youtube content
in the pipeline
incentive to do this on youtube
should i do a chat
real quick i'll show what black should
do after
after pawn f4 black should play knight
c6
and um this way it discourages e5
e5 is no longer a great move
uh but there's still some tricky traps
like knight takes c6
b takes e6 and then still pawn e5
um because if black takes then
i guess it's a game but white's actually
kind of comfy here
black losing castling rights eventually
we'll get the defile with check
so that has to be very precise
[Music]
okay um i don't think i'll dig deeper
i'll let people explore but i i showed
the main trap
i'm showing what black should do if
you're a dragon player just play knight
c6
um we can see in masters database too
that's still okay most people go for
this line
but apparently this is a vast approach
to deal with this
um so i hope most people or at least
some people
are inspired
some people saying hi to youtube other
people saying no
if this does go on youtube uh
feel free to ask follow-up questions in
the comments
oh i could do a poll let's do the whole
yeah if you're on youtube you should
watch on twitch because then you can
have
have a say of what actually makes it to
youtube should i put
this
am defeats dragon in seven moves
gm's hate him ah
oh yeah let me know what clickbait
titles i should
consider okay one minute poll
okay chat chat decides
is this going on youtube oh
yes is leading man yeah it's it's 80 20
about 100
almost 150 people saying yes
i'm voting yes oh thanks joel
subbing okay we don't even have to wait
until the poll ends
uh chat has spoken if you're watching
in the future on youtube is it selfish
of me to vote no
you can let anton know in the comments
of whether or not it's selfish to vote
no
um and yeah watch on twitch oop
yes wins the poll hey erica you're the
best
oh you're the best too